let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud and
do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well good afternoon welcome to episode
20
of let's talk the tony michaels podcast
there's some different things happening
today on the podcast
i don't know if you'll notice or not but
maybe you will
maybe you won't you know usually we
stream on
youtube live on twitter to all my
tweeples out there but today
today is the first day that we are
streaming on twitch
i have no [ __ ] idea what twitch is no
clue
i don't game so you can you can leave
all the nasty comments that you want and
tell me all the things that you want
about me because i don't i'm
i'm not a gamer so i have no idea what
twitch is i thought twitch was for
gaming but apparently people
stream podcast on there so right now as
we
speak we are on twitch
i don't know what it is i don't know how
it works but we're there
so if you're on twitch you just find me
at the tony michaels just like
anywhere else tick tock youtube the
tweet machine
and we're on there so i'll put some
links up
after today after i figure out what the
hell twitch is at the
tonymichaels.com i did open up a twitch
account uh
a while back because you know you gotta
capture the screen name
but um i don't know what twitch is
so we'll find out we'll keep going with
twitch too as long as people
watch it there i guess i have no idea i
don't know
i don't know if there's uh i don't know
if it's uh
if it's a thing where where uh you get
to replay your videos i think it replays
the videos and let you replay the videos
but
i don't know we'll figure that [ __ ] out
we'll put the links up somewhere
some [ __ ] you know how it goes but
it's wednesday
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern
like every goddamn week i'm right here
yelling and screaming into the
microphone
so for all all of you out there
listening
maybe you can hear me we've got some
things to talk about today
there's a few things that important
things that i want to get to that i want
to
you know uh really get on my [ __ ]
soapbox for
one of them is the grand jury
the criminal grand jury that has been
convened under the guise of the
new york attorney general as sy
vance the district attorney in manhattan
has convened
a criminal grand jury based on evidence
that they found
from the trump organization which who
knows what kind of needle in that
haystack
i also want to talk about the january 6
commission it sounds like there's a few
senators
who are either on board or not on board
uh
these treasonous republicans who are
still continue to
to play with this thing i think it's at
their detriment though so
you know maybe that's a good thing and
then i want to talk about marjorie
taylor green
mask mania the mask mania that's going
on out there
here on up ah yes mask video
i put on a mask for those of you just
listening not watching
the mask mania they're terrified a mask
and they're terrified now liberals
aren't going to wear mask i guess
as if wearing a mask is a liberal thing
these boneheads
but before i get to those subjects i
want to talk about a few more things
there was a shooting in san jose
california today
i was listening to it earlier i was
trying to get the podcast up i haven't
got a lot of details i wish i had more
details on that
i will probably dive into it tonight be
able to
talk about that more next week if it
even becomes relevant because there'll
probably be another mass shooting in
this country before then
it sounds like it's a workplace incident
uh
there the the shooter was declared
deceased i did hear that
for sure they confirmed that and there's
several other
uh fatalities no telling how many or
what kind of gun was used who knows
we can only guess i'm sure our guests
would be very [ __ ] good
just because this is america baby
merrick america
which in this country on the day of a
mass shooting the day after the texas
governor decides that anyone and
everyone over 21 can have a [ __ ]
handgun
doesn't matter who gives a [ __ ] as long
as you can hold it and pull the trigger
by god you're you're you're good you're
good to own a handgun
and we wonder why we wonder why we have
such a problem in this country with this
stuff
but you know i'll digress from that
issue
we will we will continue to talk about
gun issues because it will continue to
be a problem in this country from week
to week to week
the other thing i want to mention that
was lost in a lot of the pile of uh
of news yesterday late yesterday when
the grand jury hit
was the one year anniversary of the
murder of
george floyd george floyd was
murdered by derrick chauvin just over a
year ago
when he laid him on the ground and
snuffed his life out
with the knee on his neck and then was
convicted on
three counts for killing george floyd
george floyd family went and visited the
white house and
met the president of the united states
joe biden
and so i don't want that to be lost
and that is a conversation that we need
to continue to have because there
is that george floyd policing act that i
believe
uh the democrats need to make sure that
they keep pushing
on that bill let's see if we got some
comments here i i've been trying to
check the comments from you guys as long
as you
uh um trying to uh
cross talking about the gun
yeah what a [ __ ] i guess you're
referring to the governor of texas
so i'm just trying to check your
comments see how that works out for me
so let's get to the uh
main uh case of the hey you know what
let's start with this topic first the
january 6 commission
i talked about it last week i did a
video of it last week
it was called potato tomato and i might
replay it here
uh potato tomato
you know cause tourism terrorism exactly
the same [ __ ]
these republicans are playing footsie
with this commission they continue to
play footsie with the commission
apparently lisa murkowski of alaska the
senator of alaska has decided
that the january 6 commission is a good
idea
she's come to her senses on this which i
didn't doubt that
that lisa murkowski susan collins mitt
romney
a few of the others probably rob portman
especially some of these others like rob
portman that are going to be retiring
are going to come see the light
especially when chuck schumer forces a
vote
for them to be either on the side
of a uh us government that isn't
overturned by a bunch of treasonous
trump humpers
or not so i think he's going to force
him to vote
and i think that's the right thing to do
forcing the vote make them
make them put their stake in the sand
here because rather we actually get a
january 6 commission
as the bill stands right now or they
compromise something different
or there is a special counsel the
january 6th issue is going to be
is going to be investigated they they're
not going to have a choice in this
they're not either that or it's going to
be investigated in in the democratic
house and the democratic
senate through committees i mean
whatever you want
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do the
only reason why this bill scares these
republicans
is because they can be subpoenaed
because they were in the building
and their members their members were
communicating
with the insurrectionist
it's very clear that's what that's what
the fear is
that their fear is oh my god we can't
have them investigating
us that's what they're doing and i think
honestly as far as the january 6
commission as it stands in that bill
right now is republicans best
bet to get out of this unscathed if they
get they go against this january 6
commission and they investigate this in
the house they
they have a special committee that is
convened in the house and the senate
like uh benghazi benghazi benghazi
benghazi you all remember that [ __ ]
for years and years and years and
millions and millions of dollars of
taxpayers money
but if that if it becomes a criminal
matter which it
already is a criminal matter folks there
is
federal case after federal case after a
federal case
of these insurrectionists being charged
with federal felonies federal crimes
they're being held in detention centers
some of them
whining and complaining bitching and
moaning
as if they didn't do what they were
broadcasting to the world that they did
jesus christ they were live streaming it
and they're pretending like it didn't
ever happen
well it happened you [ __ ] did it you
tried to overturn the government of the
united states
whether you like it or not that's what
happened you
tried to overthrow the government of the
united states
that's what you tried to do that's what
you were actively doing
rather you whether you think it's right
or wrong or
who won or who didn't you were trying to
stop the process of the certification
that was the legal certification
of the president united states doesn't
matter if he's a republican or democrat
or joe biden
or joe schmoe donald trump or abraham
lincoln it doesn't [ __ ]
matter that's what you did
and if there was sitting members of
congress and sending members in the
senate
which i there are
that had anything to do with this
insurrection of course you're gonna be
subpoenaed
of course you're gonna be tied up but as
far as criminal goes
there's plenty of these cases that are
in criminal federal court
plenty of them and you're going to see
these cases being combined and
superseding indictments
and the main the main word to look out
here for
is conspiracy that's going to be the
main word to look out here for
as they unpack this evidence and unpile
the evidence against these folks
they turn on each other they they flip
state evidence on one another
that's what it's going to lead to is
conspiracy charges superseding
indictments where they're going to group
these people together they've already
started to do this to group these
indictments together
call it a conspiracy and that's what
these members these republican members
of congress
are [ __ ] terrified of they're [ __ ]
terrified that they're going to be tied
up in a federal criminal case of
conspiracy
because they were communicating with
these people
why do you think josh hawley was so
worried back in february when they were
having senate committee meetings
he was so [ __ ] worried about what
metadata was captured and what metadata
wasn't captured
because they're in the building their
metadata of course was captured
so of course the members of congress are
concerned about their communication with
the insurrectionist if there was
communication
[ __ ] duh [ __ ] duh
which i believe that's why liz cheney
packed her [ __ ] and said see you next
year [ __ ]
because mark my words and you can record
this and write it down
somewhere in february january and
february of 2023
liz cheney is going to be the minority
leader in the house
write it write that [ __ ] [ __ ] down
write it down spray paint it somewhere
you can hold me to it i don't give a
[ __ ] liz cheney
of wyoming will be the minority leader
in the house
february january february of 2023 write
that [ __ ] down
hold me to it
and the only reason why is because she
was the only one that can see the light
here that this
[ __ ] trumpism insurrectionist
overturned the government manga [ __ ]
this chewing on [ __ ] is not
sustainable
it's not especially especially when we
get news like we got to
yesterday about a grand jury in the
manhattan da's office
what about that i mean they always want
this what about ism what about this
what about that what about this
so let's go back real quick before we
get into the um
the old old
donny desperate donnie's day in court
let's let's go back and listen to the
potato tomato
video that i did i think i think it
really
puts in good perspective of why these
stupid [ __ ] don't want to do us january
6
commission they don't want
investigations at all i mean republicans
don't want to investigate anybody but
democrats in the first place i mean you
remember benghazi
good lord for two [ __ ] years that was
the only thing that mattered
hillary clinton the email lady you know
she was gonna be locked up for emails
and all kinds of [ __ ] she's a
criminal and all this [ __ ] well
she doesn't have a [ __ ] criminal
grand jury convening on her taxes
hmm wonder why that is
but she went and testified in front of
the republican committee the republican
congress
for 11 [ __ ] hours and
and and and she's the [ __ ] me a break
give me a [ __ ] break you goddamn weak
sons of [ __ ]
every [ __ ] last one of them are weak
week
week week
always wanting to [ __ ] put it on
somebody else never wanting to take
responsibility or accountability
god damn that would mean they'd have to
govern and come up with real policy
so let's listen to this video and maybe
i'll say some [ __ ] on the other of
course i'm going to say some [ __ ] on the
other side
tourism terrorism potato tomato
let's talk make traders kevin mccarthy
and moscow mitch mcconnell
do not want a commission looking into
the january 6th treasonous insurrection
hmm i wonder why it'd be that them and
some of their members were trying to
overthrow the government of the united
states
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock really gonna let
the seditious traders vote on whether we
should investigate them or not jesus
[ __ ] christ don't like this 911 style
commission [ __ ]
that's because they're the [ __ ]
terrorists just think about it wouldn't
it be [ __ ] swell if the 911
terrorists got to vote not to be
investigated
jesus would have been even better if
they would have had a propaganda cable
news show
called schmucker carlson or some [ __ ]
like that
how to spread the fear and their
terrorist lies around
leave your eyes it was just a regular
plane ride on a tour
of the world trade centers conor
mccarthy and all you treason is manga
trump bumpers in congress
go munch on a big bag of horse dicks
[ __ ] them
so i didn't really mean to afford offend
horses or their dicks in that video
but you know it happens it it happens
sometimes when you when you get a little
riled up about something but the
the insinuation here is that we are
going to let in this country the people
who
not only not only possibly had something
to do with coordinating
the effort of the january 6 insurrection
they want to cover up the january 6th
insurrection
they are now saying that the january 6
insurrection it never happened
don't believe your eyes that's all
[ __ ]
all that stuff about this and these
people in jail and boo hoo
boo hoo when where shut the [ __ ] up
because back in [ __ ] february and
march
ron johnson and all ted cruz and all
these other
dumb [ __ ] mo brooks marjorie taylor
green lauren bobert
they were continuing to say that it was
a false flag it was black lives matter
and it was antifa
that's what they were saying they kept
saying it over and over and over well
maybe it was antifa dressed up as trump
supporters
maybe it was antifa dressed up as trump
supporters
by the way i did a video on that too i
don't got it queued up here but
i [ __ ] got a video for everything
ron johnson specifically in a [ __ ]
committee hearing back in february
used a right-wing blog as proof of why
antifa
and anti-fascist were dressed up as
trump supporters to cause the
insurrection
well he failed to realize that all the
people that were being arrested
weren't antifa they weren't anti-fascist
they were fascists they were trump
supporters
that's what they were [ __ ] nazis
trying to overthrow the government of
the united states because they didn't
like the outcome
and by god in this country when white
people don't get the outcome that they
want
well we just might have to shoot
somebody with a gun
or take over the government and get what
we want because
if we don't get what we want by god it's
not the right thing
so that was the [ __ ] story back in
february and march continue to hear it
over and over and over again
it was all antipa well now it's just and
now it was just regular
tourism areas taking a tour of the
capital even though it was closed
because they were threatening the
capital
now we're learning more and more that
the intent was
was to make sure that there wasn't
enough force there to stop these people
from going in
and we're getting more and more of
indication of that and that's why the
[ __ ] they're scared of a january 6
insurrection
they're going to be culpable in it and
they're going to have members that
are tied up in criminal cases possibly
with the evidence that
they would uncover from a january 6
commission
there might be criminal referrals from
it who knows
probably members of congress speaking of
members of congress
we have marjorie taylor green i mean if
you want to call her a member of
congress
she has no committee assignments uh
and she's the troll of the troll of
congress right now
uh and really honestly uh you know a lot
of people they're calling
i know uh on twitter there's a
a petition going around there's your
shout out to your petition
a petition going around i think it has
about a hundred thirty hundred forty
thousand signatures right now to expel
uh marjorie taylor green from congress
uh you know it has an effect to some
some degree but i mean there's a lot to
overcome here and
it's marjorie taylor green is a lot of
craziness and a lot of
a lot of storytelling that you have to
overcome and what i mean by that
is she'll believe just about anything
she wants to believe as long as it fits
her narrative
and as long as as long as her narrative
is the way that she wants it she doesn't
give a [ __ ] what you say shouldn't give
a [ __ ] what you sign
her point is to grift anyways that's all
this is one big old [ __ ] grift
i mean she continues continues continues
to
to badger aoc to debate her and all's
that is is to
send out fundraising emails
to keep the to keep the faucet going
because they lost the faucet from
corporate america
corporate corporate america that's why
another reason why liz cheney tuck
tailed and run
[ __ ] you i'll wait two years i'll be the
leader
we'll have the money that's ultimately
what's gonna happen to the party is the
party's gonna have to decide do we
do we want corporate money or do we not
i bet they do
these people who love [ __ ] money
so marjorie taylor green decides to uh
throw fireballs at social media this
week and she she's at an
american of first event with with the
the
the almost uh indicted
sex trafficker matt getz allegedly
alleged sex trafficker it's alleged
at this point uh but but she's at an
american first nazi party
event uh with
matt gatz and and uh paul gosar and uh
she
she says to into a microphone
that that wearing mask
is is like it's like the holocaust
which i mean immediately immediately was
a mistake for her now the republicans
were
slow to get to the point to where they
condemned her i mean even
yesterday the universe aligned so
[ __ ] weird yesterday that ben shapiro
finn shapiro was on twitter saying
marjorie taylor green is an idiot
and her argument for the mask and the
holocaust is boneheaded
and derogatory basically i mean i could
read you the [ __ ] tweet but
it is ben shapiro so who gives a [ __ ]
but the point is
that the universe yesterday made me and
ben shapiro agree
that's what that's what that's that's
the type of [ __ ] that marjorie taylor
green is peddling
it makes me and ben shapiro agree which
means the universe is all kinds of
[ __ ] up
especially when she's talking into a
goddamn microphone
i mean let alone the just simple fact
that
wearing a mask to make sure that you're
protecting your your your family your
friends your co-workers
uh strangers at a grocery store from a
deadly pathogen
is definitely not the same as wearing a
a gold jewish star
on your on your arm
then are sewn to your jacket that the
nazi would make you wear
let alone that fact we're talking about
leading
an entire group of people to gas
chambers
okay and what's really pissing them off
about this
mask these masks and it's masked mania
now
they've had mask mania for for for over
a year now
because they they're anti-masters you
know i mean it was a hundred different
stories just like the insurrection
the mask made you sick the mask is what
was killing people
it wasn't actually the virus the mass
gives you a bacteria
something about freedom and patriotism
and all kinds of [ __ ] i mean just on
and on and on and when constitution
and you can't force me and all this
garbage
and continuing and continuing and
continuing this [ __ ]
when originally from the beginning they
said well we're not
sure about the mass then they figured
out the mass [ __ ] work they're like
put on your [ __ ] mask
it'll help us get to the point to where
we get a vaccine now that we have a
vaccine they're saying
hey if you're vaccinated you don't need
mask
and the data is showing per the cdc
that that's the truth that if you're
vaccinated you don't need a mask
so they're now what's happening what's
happening folks is they're getting
really [ __ ] pissed off now that
liberals are taking off their mask
liberals as if it's only liberals that
are wearing masks
which is another boneheaded thing it was
people who have [ __ ]
manners i mean
i i'm fully vaccinated i'm fully
inoculated i'm way past my two weeks
i've had two moderna shots
now i don't wear a mask when i go into a
store that doesn't require it
unless i'm really close to someone who
has a mask on
what do i mean by that if i go into a
store
and there's someone close by i have my
mask in my pocket
here's my mask and my mask in my pocket
if i get close to someone who has a mask
on i pop my mask on
they got a mask on i don't know the
reason why maybe they're sick
maybe they haven't been fully vaccinated
i don't know
i don't know does it really matter to me
it does
in the sense that i'm trying to be
courteous to them
now on the same hand if i go into a
store that still requires mask
i will put on a [ __ ] mask these
people think this little piece of cloth
somehow is gonna
control your brain
that's the masked mania that's this
nonsense is queueing on [ __ ]
is they think a simple little piece of
cloth over your face to prevent your
community or your family
or someone else from getting a deadly
pathogen that somehow that creates you
to have mind control
now if your belief is that you put a
little piece of cloth over your face
and that and that is going to cause you
to have
uh brain damage or mind control or
somehow it's the government controlling
you
or you're a sheep or some [ __ ] like that
you need to look deep inside yourself
shave the wool off
because you have bought [ __ ] hook
line sinker you are a dumb
[ __ ] if you think a mask brainwashes you
and controls you because you're going to
be really [ __ ] disappointed here in
about six or eight months
because the other great news that we had
yesterday is 50 percent
50 percent of the the united states
adult population is now fully vaccinated
50 percent folks we're barreling in on
real herd immunity here
in some areas some areas are going to
live with this virus for years and years
and years until they get their heads out
of their ass
we are barreling in here on herd
immunity
in the next six or eight months when
that happens there's not going to be a
lot of people still wearing masks
other than people who aren't vaccinated
who they require to wear masks by the
way
most of these places and then when i say
places i mean capitalist private
businesses if you're not vaccinated
they're gonna either make you
they're gonna make you take a test and
they're probably gonna make you wear a
[ __ ] mask
so even if you can go to a concert and
you have the right testing
to get into the building they're
probably going to make you put on a mask
because you're not vaccinated
so this is the mania that is going to
ensue on these people
is that they can't get it through your
skull that hey if you just get
inoculated
if you just get inoculated then you
won't have a mask and i had a good
experience
this last week of watching watching
someone try to maneuver themselves
in a mask situation
so as you notice the setup here it looks
a little
different right the the the video looks
a little different
i got me a brand new imac
a 24-inch imac i'm not promoting imac i
don't get paid by imac
i mean i wish i did it'd be nice to get
a free one but
a shout out to apple but i'm not
sons of [ __ ] but i got me a brand new
imac
my chromebook was full i actually did my
podcast from my chromebook it got full
you [ __ ] filled it up me yapping into
the microphone and recording this stuff
filled up my goddamn macbook so i had to
get a mac
well i didn't have to but [ __ ] it i
wanted to [ __ ] up
so i go to the apple store and
i had already pre-ordered i was just
waiting to pick up my order
and across the way there was a lady with
her with her son um
i don't know he looked like he was about
14 or 15.
that the worker from apple was standing
there with his paper mask on
i'm assuming that's the one apple gave
him because all the apple employees kind
of had that
type of mask on it was a special looking
type of apple mask you know what i mean
you know what i mean everything with
apple has to be special
i'm gonna tell you about that here in a
minute about the box that this thing
came in because holy [ __ ] you talk about
a sexy [ __ ] box
god damn the computer buying a computer
is just worth the [ __ ] box
i saved it anyways so i'm standing
across away from this lady
who is trying to enter the store and she
says she has a medical exemption
the worker says sorry ma'am you can't go
in the store without a mask
she says well we have medical exemptions
he said oh okay well that's okay
no problem you still can't go in the
store
you have to have a mask she says well we
have a medical exemption
and it really wasn't getting through a
thick skull so i don't i don't know if
the mask would have helped uh
you know open up her brain to figure out
what he was saying
but he said ma'am no one is to enter the
store without a mask
we don't have a policy about medical
exemptions
we don't have one we have a mass policy
and right now
our our company-wide policies to still
wear masks
so if you want to go in the store you
got to wear a mask if you don't want to
go in the store
absolutely fine no problem you can order
online we'll bring your [ __ ] out to you
i mean he didn't say it in that many
words that would have been what i said
but you know
how confrontational am i so
on and on and on it went i went to the
store i came out of the store they were
still arguing about whether she was
gonna go in the store or not
it's really simple people it's really
[ __ ] simple over the next six or
eight months
all these companies are gonna lift their
mask mandates but some of them are still
gonna have some in place for a while
some places are still gonna have them
you're still gonna have to wear masks
even though you're
you're vaccinated or not and the best
part is the best part is
last year all these people who didn't
want to wear masks who didn't give a
[ __ ] about lockdowns who wouldn't did
all the [ __ ] that they wanted to do
over this next year it's going to be
really really great
to watch them not be able to do a single
[ __ ] thing because they won't wear a
mask and they won't get vaccinated
it's gonna be fantastic stay at home
stay your [ __ ] asses at home for a
year
see how it feels you dumb [ __ ]
now let me get back to this box
because this box is very important for
this imac
i can't even believe i can't even tell
you how incredible this box is
and and if you go because there's always
there's been people buy this 24-inch mac
you got to go online i'm sure there's
gonna i didn't make a uh unboxing video
but you you know how it is when you
slide a new iphone box it gives up
sound oh this thing this box
it had a seal on it and it's got the
cloth handle
you open the box and then you it
you gotta go watch it go find a video go
google that [ __ ] you'll know what i'm
talking about
okay so so
on and on and on with the mask mania
this marjorie taylor green
she compares it to the holocaust uh
which again
jesus [ __ ] christ do we really have
to let marjory taylor and
green know what the holocaust actually
was i think that's the problem here
the problem is is marjorie taylor green
uh
is a neo-nazi and she denies that the
holocaust even happens
and the reason why she denies it because
she doesn't even know what happened
and because she doesn't know what
happened she she compares it to anything
she [ __ ] wants
and to compare the extermination of a
group of people
in in in germany in europe in the 1930s
and 1940s
to putting a piece of cloth over your
face for several months
to make sure that you don't spread a
deadly pathogen to your family or
community
to keep them safe and healthy
is [ __ ] boneheaded but it's not
surprising coming out of her because
she's stunningly
a stupid piece of [ __ ]
so i did do a video about the the mask
so let me play that i might as well play
it here and then we'll move on to
something different have you ever
noticed if masks were semi-automatic
that these q and on trump humpers would
require them in churches
schools day cares and to order big macs
you know for protection and [ __ ] get a
[ __ ] clue you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
them
now the one thing i do see that could
happen in the next six or eight months
is they're so pissed off this masked
mania
and again it's that they're mad that
people are taking
off mask now because you remember
just a few days ago governor governor
whitmer of michigan
was uh there was a picture of her online
of her in a bar having a drink
she's been fully inoculated for several
several several weeks
and she's enjoying a drink with a group
of vaccinated people apparently
following the cdc guidelines and they
roasted her you know it was her eat cake
moment which
th the mask thing is actually the e cake
but you know
we'll we'll leave that alone for now
but they were so pissed off that
governor whitmer didn't have her mask on
trump pumpers anti-masters were
mad were mad they were pissed
off that governor whitmer didn't have a
mask on
so they've gone from we won't wear mask
mask or bad mass
kill you to what the hell
the democratic governor of michigan
isn't going to wear a mask
now what the [ __ ] do we do that's the
mask mania
the mask mania is they can't they're not
gonna be able to [ __ ] about mask
anymore
it's gonna be almost non-existent other
than the people who aren't
vaccinated literally the places that you
go the things that you are gonna do
the people who are going to have the
mask on or either people who are number
one
uncomfortable because they know there
are people not vaccinated
are number two people who are not
vaccinated they're not
vaccinated the mask in the next
eight months to a year is gonna is
probably going to be a
very loud signal of someone who is not
vaccinated that is probably how people
are going to view it
because everyone's tired of the [ __ ]
mask i mean there's some people that
like the
you know the mask because they can hide
their face and they don't have to show
themselves when they go in the grocery
store because who wants to look at other
strange human beings
i don't some people don't but
this mass thing is going to turn around
on them and that's why they're losing
their [ __ ] minds so be prepared over
the next several months
for them to struggle with what they
believe about mask
because that's really the struggle that
they have here is what they believe
because they don't know what they
believe anymore that's why they're all
over the goddamn
map so
that brings us to the last subject and
the greatest subject of the day and i
held it for last
and by god if you made it to this part
of the podcast are you in for some good
[ __ ] i don't know maybe not
i'm talking about the grand jury that
was
con that is going to be convened for the
criminal
trial possible criminal indictments
of the trump trump organization and
possibly people in the trump
organization
that's what they're going to be looking
into and cybance the manhattan d.a
under the guise of the state law in new
york city or new york excuse me new york
has convened this grand jury uh
and apparently they're gonna they're
gonna work on this case
three days a week for up to six months
holy god three days a week
i mean that has to terrify the [ __ ] out
of the trump family
i mean jared ivanka don jr
eric donald himself alan weisselberg
these people don't work three days a
week collectively
this has got to scare the [ __ ] out of
them
and and a grand jury basically has the
power to
do whatever they want and seek whatever
piece of evidence that they want
there's no judge or court telling them
well you can't admit that as evidence
well you can't we can't show the jury
that
that's not how it works a grand jury is
just to decide if they're going to
indict someone so they can look at any
any evidence that they want they can
overturn almost
any rock that they want and the greatest
part is is not only do they have the
trump organization's tax returns but
apparently they have donald trump's tax
returns
that's what the court case back in
february was about
you remember the supreme court scotus
decided back in february that yeah of
course
of course the manhattan d.a in a
criminal case can have someone's tax
returns
and who gives a [ __ ] if that person says
they're under audit or not
give not two facts at this point
and the grand in the the supreme court
gave the the ability for cybants to
show those tax returns to a grand jury
back in february i did a video about it
i mean
again with the video thing so let me
show you the video that i did it's it's
i think
this video let me check it here on uh
i believe that this video is going to be
my first video on twitter that reached
100 000 views
i know that sounds crazy but um i'm kind
of happy about that
and the reason why is because the uh
it's about just over ninety two thousand
so we're gonna get to a hundred thousand
that video
and it explains the video very well now
a lot of people are confused they keep
asking me
jesus christ where is it still snowing
well i did this video
back in february when that's when that
supreme court decision was made
um and i seen the writing on the wall
back then of what was going to happen
when they made that decision that a
grand jury was going to see the trump
organization's tax returns
why do you think he's been hiding them
i mean this isn't complicated trump is
not a [ __ ] mystery
at all he's not a mystery whatever he
says he's projecting
he's projecting and when he's trying to
hide something
that's where the evidence is so
let me play that and we'll talk about it
desperate donnie's day in court
let's talk so our ex-cry baby in chief
finds out that his supreme court justice
nominees
didn't do him that much [ __ ] good
they allow the manhattan d.a to present
this
douchebags tax returns to a grand jury
we get to find out what this fat slob
was hiding this whole time
you dumb [ __ ] what are we gonna find out
there you
cheeto dust mobster is it all the porn
star and abortion hush payment we're
gonna be the [ __ ] laundering of
russian's money the bet is that it's a
dick contest to this [ __ ] fool and
we're gonna find out he's
[ __ ] flat broke whatever the reason
is you fascist sack of [ __ ]
you better start learning how to keister
big macs and diet coke
you dumb [ __ ] in the end i guess this
[ __ ] wasn't that good at climbing and
stuff
[ __ ] them so i guess i called it i don't
know
maybe not you know a lot of the the the
maga crowd and the comments uh
they don't like that video and i like it
there's no facts
in there there's no facts
good luck with that narrative so
if we break down exactly um
what could happen here and and because i
think
that it's not just about this grand jury
that cybants
um the manhattan d.a is is planning on
convening here i i think this goes much
deeper
i think it's going to be much more
extensive
i think the grand jury if there is
indictments that come out of the grand
jury at the manhattan da's office which
it seems like it's probably going to be
some sort of
rico case or tax case
i mean what rico the rico case is
is before rico they really had to pin
evidence on a certain person
uh to really tie him down if you if you
had done any studying on
the organized crime in this country you
remember that
that al capone was not not
charged and not imprisoned for murder
uh and he wasn't imp prison for any
theft or
or anything like that he was he was
he was imprisoned for tax fraud uh what
they could prove on him specifically
well what changed in the 1960s 70s and
really the 80s was the main key thing uh
was rico
now rico what that meant because these
mob bosses
uh i can't even believe it a former
president i'm comparing to my bosses
but the mob bosses would uh
insulate themselves with their
underlings they would give orders down
and down and those people would do the
dirty work so there's really no evidence
to
to to to tie back to that mob boss
and really it wasn't until they started
doing a lot of wiretapping and
and uh devices to to
work their way up to that high-end mob
boss to
show that it was a grand conspiracy
and as long as they could tie it didn't
have they didn't have to have direct
evidence
with rico that someone was involved they
could use rico to get that direct
evidence
so it could turn into that because uh if
you look at a lot of these stories
on some of these trump buildings and
some of these uh trump deals that he's
done over the years
they they got they got the smell of
money laundering all over them
um and if if that evidence is inside
those tax returns
and also inside alan weisselberg's mind
because i think that's where a lot of
this stuff lives
i think that's the key point here is
weisselberg
weiszelman why so who is it
i can't even keep track anymore there's
so many of these [ __ ] bags that you
gotta keep track of who is who
michael cohen paul manafort roger stone
matt gatz
joel greenberg god damn the list goes on
and on
mo mo brooks goes-r
it just goes on and on and on this list
of [ __ ] boxes
that we have to contend with [ __ ] me
never [ __ ] ending
now i believe the cfo of the trump
organization is the key
and it seems like that is what has
triggered
uh this grand jury because if you if you
look back at some of these events
uh the the daughter-in-law of
weisselberg
is that who it is someone give me a
comment here hey weisselmann
weaselman okay weisselman not weiselberg
i'm getting confused with
greenberg and there's just so many
people tied up in these trump schemes
that it's
it gets [ __ ] confusing jesus
so the cfo of the trump organization
his daughter-in-law uh apparently
did not get a good deal and a divorce so
she decided that she was going to put
the squeeze on them
and that seems to be where
some of some of this some of this is
starting to come from
but if you if you turn back the dial a
bit
and you go back to the case of michael
cohen michael cohen
testified in front of the democrat house
committee
and even aoc asked him almost directly
if he thought there was any money
laundering and he
basically said well yeah um michael
cohen would probably know
and michael cohen would probably know
the key that would unlock that door
and at that point it was weisselman
that's kind of what led to all this is
that donald trump knows the cfo knows
the children know they all know
it's all part of putting money in their
pockets
that's the whole point that's the entire
[ __ ] scheme is money
that's it and you just follow that just
follow the money
i mean jesus christ michael cohen showed
it there was a check
when donald trump was president of the
united states he signed a check to pay a
hush payment to a porn star
now i'm not exactly against people
paying porn stars money
but when it's the president of the
united states the current sitting prison
the united states to keep someone from
shutting up
is that really the moral standard that
we want to have someone running our
country
christians out there you christians out
there is that really the [ __ ] moral
standard that we want to have
is a guy who has to pay hush money to a
porn star again
i'm not against people giving porn stars
money
i'm not but it's is that really the
standard that we want
is that where we're going to go with
with with the president united states of
who we want to lead our country
and to represent us around the world and
here
come on open up your [ __ ] bibles and
read a few things and then make
decisions
not the other way around but michael
cohen
that was a key point and i believe the
investigation into the trump
organization
he shed a lot of light of who knows what
and that's the most important part of
this case that's the most important
part about it all if it goes to trial
who's going to flip
when they're going to flip what they
know when they know and who they're
going to point out
and i believe michael cohen has already
started to do a lot of that
i also find it very funny and very uh
coincidental that we see superseding
indictments and a guilty plea from joel
greenberg down in florida
you know the matt gets sex trafficking
case
the the sugar daddy guy down in florida
that was helping matt gatz pay prost
underage prostitutes on his venmo
account
that guy
i believe that that sounds like it could
be
maybe i don't know i mean it's all kind
of coincidental that rudy giuliani was
had a no knock raid
from the fbi the same federal
governments
that's prosecuting joel greenberg and
looking in the matte gats
and his activity on his electronic
devices i
find it kind of you know coincidental
that rudy giuliani's devices were
were seized because you know what
those names pop up in a lot of places
rudy giuliani was
donald trump's personal personal
personal attorney
he was also representing him during the
the whole big lie
election fraud [ __ ] running around
the country and all these state
legislators
farting on people like literally he was
farting on people
jen ellis was one of them said next one
you see how these names are so many
so many [ __ ] scumbags that you have
to keep track of
good lord
but rudy giuliani shows up in the
greenberg case
yes joel greenberg jesus see the names
the names
so many of these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
rudy giuliani's name shows up in that
story
and the reason why is because apparently
joel greenberg
allegedly paid roger stone 250 000.
to lobby for a pardon for him for the
crime the sex trafficking crimes that
he's now pled guilty to
a pardon from trump before trump left
office
well if you remember back i believe it
was january 17th as the day you can go
check this [ __ ]
but the news of the day was that ivanka
trump
jared kushner and rudy giuliani were
walking into the white house and
possibly going and petitioning for
pardons
well guess who roger stone had contact
with with rudy giuliani and
jared kushner about
about a pardon for a guy down in florida
for sex trafficking hmm
rudy giuliani name appears in that case
he also appears in the case for ukraine
that's why they say they
got his electronic devices but is it a
coincidence
is it a coincidence that they get the
tax returns now
that the new york state attorney general
decides to change her case from civil to
criminal
because it looks like there's criminal
uh transactions
they're not really saying what but
there's some transactions that are
happening and she's going to join psy
vance
and this is conveniently after rudy
giuliani was rated with his electronic
devices
this all seems just convenient doesn't
it now there's a lot of coincidence i
don't believe that
uh you know the plan or whatever these q
anon people believe
these conspiracy theories but
it is kind of convenient that all these
people are popping up in all these cases
that are in court and currently people
that are pleading guilty and under
indictment or
under investigation of a grand jury
don't you think
hmm kind of [ __ ] convenient
so maybe me surmising that donald trump
should learn how to keister
big macs and diet cokes is not that far
off
from the allegations that are being made
in the public sphere here
i don't know i guess we'll see a lot of
people are surmising that maybe donald
trump
you know he's teflon don nothing touches
him
he's going to get out of this like he's
got at everything else well there's one
thing
specifically about this case and
manhattan d.a
has convened this criminal grand jury
that is the most important part about
this
court proceeding if you want to call it
that
court maneuvering prosecutor maneuvering
is donald trump has never been this
close
to a criminal indictment he's been very
close and actually been part
of plenty of civil indictments him and
his father
were uh were in civil cases uh
in the late 70s and early 80s about
housing discrimination they were civil
charges not criminal
that's the most significant thing to me
about
this case is that this
is criminal they are investigating
criminal charges
even the mueller investigation which
everyone's been yelling and screaming
about the
bill barr memo here's another [ __ ]
name that you can [ __ ] up bill barr
another scumbag in the trump universe
the
list goes on and on and on and on
and god damn you have to have [ __ ] 12
days a
[ __ ] week 60 hours of a day to keep
up with these [ __ ] criminals
these dumb [ __ ] but everyone's yelling
and screaming about the billbar
memo well even the bob or the the even
the
mueller investigation was not a criminal
matter
now he made criminal referrals out of
that investigation
but that investigation itself was not
criminal there was no criminal
proceedings in that investigation
i believe one of the actual charges that
came from that investigation
was uh paul manafort robert gates
and and roger stone and there were some
conviction there's some prison charges
and now
there were pardons i wonder if that was
to keep mouse shut
so this is a criminal proceeding
directly tied to the trump organization
which donald trump and his children
and the cfo weisselmann
ran so if you think that this is not any
different he's gonna skate on this you
manga trump uppers out there
you are dumb [ __ ]
if you think that they're gonna bring a
case in the manhattan da's office and
convene a grand jury because there isn't
compelling evidence against a former
president united states
and the company the private company that
him and his family run
i i i would convince you that there's a
blood-sucking democrat cabal somewhere
that is trying to control the universe
and hillary clinton is is the is the
leader
of it and it's all hidden in her goddamn
emails
i would try to convince you of that
which i would
probably convince you pretty goddamn
easy
so thank you for joining me we're at
like 54 and a half minutes that's pretty
good timing today
i talked almost the entire time i hardly
took a [ __ ] breath did you notice
that
i got up early i'm a little i'm a little
tired but man i powered through this
podcast
powered through it
hey jack abroad says pizza in a basement
yeah
i'll convince you that there is a
non-existent basement at a pizza parlor
somewhere
where they're they're they're doing all
kinds of weird stuff that you would
come up with in your mind
so i appreciate you joining me today
again if you like the podcast
keep watching subscribe to the youtube
channel we're going to be over on twitch
now whatever the [ __ ] that means
so if you can follow me on twitch go
over there it's the tony michaels
so i'll figure that out i have no idea
what the hell that means but we'll
figure out the twitch in the next couple
weeks i just
i just activated it the [ __ ] today so
hey i don't know i don't know
i don't know maybe it makes me look like
a boomer
but i have no idea what the [ __ ] twitch
is or how it works we're gonna figure
that out as time goes on
so follow me over there if you're over
there follow me on twitter
and if you want to support the podcast
you can buy a hat a [ __ ] hat
tony michael's hat you can go to
thetonymichaels.com or you can go to the
merch store and you can get some
stickers
stickers [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
stickers if you want some [ __ ]
stickers there's coffee mugs on there
their shirts now all that all
any of that money goes towards the
podcast uh for our streaming software
here so that way we can simulcast on all
these channels
and then it gets recorded on youtube and
then i put it up on apple podcast
and also also it's on spotify and
there's other directories
podcast directories that it's on and you
can search and find those at let's talk
the tony michaels podcast either on
apple podcast or spotify or your your
podcast directory and you can listen to
me because after it's recorded the
greatest part is
what i do is i sit right here at my
computer
and i load it but it cost me money to
publish it so that's one thing that it
does cost money to publish
and add the software so that's what all
that money goes to if you buy stickers
or a hat
and i appreciate any support rather it's
just liking and watching
and or or getting a sticker and putting
a [ __ ] sticker
on your on your mirror or something i
don't know you stick it anywhere one you
stick it on your ass if you want to
all right guys thanks a lot i appreciate
it let's see if we have any more uh
comments before we go
they're talking about twitch here but i
still don't know what it is i'm really
gonna have to do some research into what
this
what this twitch thing is i thought it
was gaming but apparently it's a podcast
and recording thing too it's like a
youtube we'll see how that works um
hopefully i'll get better at it and if
we can i don't know if you can load
videos i might
if people start following over there i
might i might even load some more videos
might even load uh past podcast episodes
on to twitch if you can do that i don't
know if you can so
we'll find out if we can do that or not
but thanks for joining me today
don't don't forget next week same god
damn time
same god damn place three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern
youtube live twitter live and now twitch
live
don't forget before i forget
one more thing before we go [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime
follow tony on social media at the tony
michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after me
[ __ ] them